في طريق ترابي هادئ في La vie ،
يبدو متجر تصليح السيارات الصغير هذا مثل أي متجر
آخر ،
لكنه يلعب دورًا حيويًا في
المقاومة المدنية في أوكرانيا ،
إنه عمل شاق يشعل هذه الشاحنة العادية
للتوجه إلى
الخطوط الأمامية
الذين  يعمل عادةً كمصمم جرافيك
يخطط لقيادته إلى الخطوط الأمامية
بنفسه ،
كل رحلة مليئة بالعواطف المليئة
بالعمل الجاد ومليئة بالبهجة أيضًا لأنني
أستطيع أن أكون جزءًا من شيء أكبر يمكنني
إحضار بعض الأشياء التي تجعلنا على الأقل
أقرب إلى النصر
كانت عليانا تنظم تبرعات بالسيارات
للجيش الأوكراني منذ أن
غزت روسيا شبه جزيرة القرم في عام 2014.
وقد زادت جهودها الآن بخمس
رحلات حتى الآن هذا العام ، لذا فأنت
بمفردك لمدة 17
ساعة في هذه السيارة الكبيرة
التي تعرفها صغيرة مثلك  هل
أنت خائف؟
هذا هو دائمًا ما يكون أقوى ،
هذا هو حب المدنيين في وطننا الأم
هنا يائسين لمساعدة
الجيش ، لكن يمكنهم التبرع بالمال
لاستيراد أكبر عدد ممكن من السيارات ، هذه
الشاحنة الآن مطلية وجاهزة
لتذهب إلى دونسك في شرق أوكرانيا
حيث كانت القوات الروسية تقصف
بلا هوادة  لأكثر من شهر
جرح وقتل الآلاف من
المدنيين وضرب جنود القوات الأوكرانية
يقولون إن التبرعات مثل هذه
كانت لا تقدر بثمن لأنهم يستعدون لصراع طويل
لا يمكن التنبؤ به حقًا في
بعض الأحيان قد تنجو السيارة لشهر
أو شهرين ولكن أحيانًا في اليوم التالي
يمكن أن يكون تحت نيران العدو ويتم
تدميره ، إنها رحلة 800 ميل من
المنافسة إلى سلوفينيا
وليست السيارة التي ستمنحها جوليانا لأولئك الذين
يقاتلون الصندوق الخلفي مليئة بالزي الرسمي الجديد
والمعدات العسكرية والكثير من الوقود
كما تتخيلها.  ستساعد هذه الإمدادات
الجنود مثل
صهرها وأصدقائها المقربين الآخرين
الذين يقاتلون الآن في  في الشرق ،
تناولنا القهوة قبل يومين من بدء الحرب ،
هم الآن في الخطوط الأمامية ، لكن
حقيقة أنني أستطيع مساعدة الجنود
تجعلني أقل قلقًا من
رحلتها الغادرة ، وأتمنى أن
تمهد الطريق لأوكرانيا حرة